DC universes Titans has provided plenty
of Easter eggs for fans to find there
are callbacks to old classics set-pieces
and iconic comic book locations and a
whole lot more
here are the easter eggs you might have
missed in Titan's season 2 fairly early
in the episode Aqualad we see Arthur
light aka dr. light torturing dr. Jacob
Finley
for starters their conversation
indicates the two have a history I love
this gladiator look reminds me the time
you went Spartacus on professor su after
failing the freshman physics final we
don't hear a lot of specifics but the
gist of it seems to be that Finley has
won respect and fame on dr. lights
shoulders they make a reference to
failed work light did that Finley was
able to improve upon and subsequently
take all the credit for but that's just
the tip of the iceberg regarding the
relationship between these two let's
back up the name Jacob Finley comes
directly from the comics when we first
meet Finley in 1989 secret origins
number 37 he appears as an apparition to
arthur light in a doctor light costume a
flashback unfolds in which we learned
Finley was the original dr. light before
Arthur light took up the name
and unlike Arthur light Finley wanted to
use his abilities for good after Finley
dies Arthur takes his suit and his
powers but continues to be haunted by
Finley's ghost when dr. light tortures
Jacob Finley a blinking you'll miss it
easter egg pays tribute not to a comic
book or another DC inspired TV show or
movie but to one of titans crew when dr.
light lays a copy of a magazine in front
of Finley Finley's faces on the cover
and the story on him was written by one
James uses well James uses isn't a
d-list supervillain or a well-kept comic
book secret he's no ding-dong daddy
in other words instead James Anthony
uses is the set designer for every
episode of titans second season in the
last few years
OSS has also made a name for himself as
a set designer on series like the
expanse and Star Trek Discovery much of
the episode Aqualad revolves around the
doomed garthe trying to woo Donna Troy
in one of his conversations with Donna
Garth teases her with a joke about her
tongue
Twister of a homeland the mascara to the
mascara its mascara yes this is possibly
a reference to a line of makeup that
most fans have probably forgotten about
in 2011 MAC Cosmetics released a Wonder
Woman themed line of makeup products
complete with Wonder Woman artwork by
renowned artist Michael all read the
line included such products as obey me
nail polish Athena's kiss lip gloss and
yes the mascara mascara toward the
beginning of the fifth episode of season
two Garr goes into Rachel's bedroom and
finds a weird oily black substance
flowing out of and around Raven as she
sleeps eventually it cuts gar and later
in the episode Rachel shows fresh cuts
to Cori on her own back from the nightly
events we don't know what the exact
nature of this energy is yet though it
seems obvious it has something to do
with how Trigon altered Rachel's powers
in the season premiere Asgar enters the
room there's a shot of something that
should probably be raising some alarm
bells that we have yet to hear anyone
mentioning it posted on a cork board
above Rachel's desk are a number of
images that wouldn't necessarily be
disturbing if they weren't being drawn
by the daughter of a demon in fact
they're exactly what you'd expect any
given evil demonic possessed kid to draw
before they go fulbright burn on
everyone around them
Rachel's creative side seems to be very
interested in black
abyssal holes which is likely connected
with the darkness continuing to emerge
from Rachel herself fans have been
waiting for the return of Superboy and
Krypto ever since the first season's
finale gave us a post-credits scene
showing the pair busting out of a Cadmus
laboratory they finally got their wish
with the second season sixth episode
Connor after revisiting that post-credit
scene and giving us a corny commercial
for Cadmus Superboy and Krypto escaped
from the lab in the cold open of Connor
and find themselves faced with a skyline
of the famous city of Metropolis
thankfully the show's creative team
don't forget an important detail
metropolis is most well-known landmark
The Daily Planet building the workplace
of Clark Kent the daily planets most
recognizable physical feature is the
massive
ringed globe on top of the building the
Titans crew does a wonderful job with
the detail you wouldn't notice it if you
weren't looking for it but once you do
there's no mistaking what it is after
his escape Connor walks around
metropolis with Krypto taking everything
in and seeming to revel in it at one
point he stops and raises his arms
taking in the Rays of the Sun visibly
overjoyed to be among humanity rather
than locked away in a lab a nearby
street vendor is selling shirts caps and
other metropolis memorabilia including a
black shirt bearing the Superman logo
the park behind the street vendors is
Centennial Park the fictional metropolis
is answer to New York's Central Park in
DC Comics Centennial Park is the home of
the memorial raised to honor Superman
after he dies in battle with the
rampaging villain doomsday it's a
fitting location for Superboy to be as
he experiences his own form of rebirth
everything that he is experiencing is
for the very first time
in Falun mercy graves and our commandos
raid Titans tower recapturing Connor and
crypto seeing garz transformation powers
in action
mercy decides to bring gar along for
good measure the episode ends with gar
in a lounge like prison watching the
1939 classic The Wizard of Oz it turns
out that there's some meaning to the
choice the scene gar is watching brings
the wicked witches flying monkeys into
view and once you see them it's
difficult to not think of the moment
earlier in the episode when Rachel's
powers summoned a winged gargoyle who
hunts down her new friends abusive
father in both this episode and the
following episode there are references
and reminders of Dorothy's trip to Oz
while speaking to the phantom Bruce
Wayne dick refers to death strokes tiny
tin heart a reference to Oz's tin man
who has no heart and considering the
brain surgery forced on gar in that same
episode he could see him singing if I
only had a brain the two Luthor's
mentioned the most in Connor are the
infamous lex luthor and his father
Lionel but we briefly see at least one
more member of the family
Lena Luthor unlike her brother she's
actually smiling in the family portrait
that Conner finds in the Luthor home and
she's looking lovingly at the same man
we know beat Lex after he'd had too much
to drink
Lena Luthor has kind of a crazy history
in DC Comics depending on which comic
book you read and when it was published
Lena Luthor is either Lex Luthor's
sister or she's his daughter
she's risen to prominence more recently
more so on the small screen than in the
comics Katie McGrath plays Lena luthor
in CW's Supergirl series and became a
regular in the third season most episode
of Titans take their titles from the
name of the character who would be the
focus of that particular our season 2
7th episode Bruce Wayne is a departure
in that while Bruce Wayne shows up quite
a bit it isn't really Bruce Wayne when
Dick Grayson's mentor appears to him it
becomes clear that this isn't the real
Wayne but dick Grayson's insecurities
haunting him in the form of his
surrogate father one such scene is when
dick goes to a club looking for
information on Deathstroke and Wayne
appears on stage
in an unexpected turn of events he gives
us a tribute to the late Adam West oh
joy rapture
ian's Glenn's dance is brief but
longtime Batman fans undoubtedly
recognized it as a callback to Adam
West's campy portrayal of Batman from
the 60s in Batman's first episode Batman
finds himself in a disco with the
Riddler's lovely assistant pulling the
trademark moves Glens Bruce Wayne gives
us on titans and Jericho Slade finally
tells his son the truth about who he is
the story is told through a series of
flashbacks all leading up to Jericho
meeting his father alone in the church
to finally get the truth the meeting
doesn't go well
viewers were no doubt expecting to get
some concrete answers from that Meetup
but sharp eared viewers may have gotten
a wealth of info even earlier in the
episode during the episodes first
flashback you might have missed a super
quick mention of a clandestine group
called hive he was part of a special
unit called hive try to relax
[Music]
hive has been a mainstay in DC Comics
since the early 80s when they first
appear in the pages of New Teen Titans
their acronym stood for hierarchy of
international vengeance and
extermination the group has a long
history of animosity with the Teen
Titans including close ties with the
group known as the fearsome five which
includes villains we've already seen on
Titans like shimmer and dr. light season
two's ninth episode atonement opens with
the Titans disbanding leaving guard to
watch over Connor and Titans Tower
the subsequent montage shows gar going
from optimistic and excited to board and
stir-crazy in three days along with
everything else the post-its car leaves
in the kitchen reflect his devolve a
mental state through the helpful
influence of a couple of great songs and
films on the first day he posts fitter
happier more productive a line from
Radiohead's
fitter happier by day two his emotions
are already sagging a bit too any writes
always look on the bright side of life
which is the song that concludes the
classic 1979 religious satire monty
python's life of brian it is a little
strange that Gard chooses this phrase
since the characters singing it aren't
exactly in an enviable position at the
time my day 3 gar is officially
stir-crazy and he lets us know by
calling back to the 1980 thriller The
Shining rather than any affirmations
Garr writes out all work and no play
makes gar a dull boy on multiple
post-its and sticks them up in a row a
post-it tribute to the moment in the
shining when Wendy discovers what her
homicidal husband has really been up to
all winter dick Grayson's time in prison
represents a major turning point for his
character arc thanks in part to three
new cellmates at first it seems like the
three are more than happy with the idea
of killing dick but eventually Grayson
learns his cell mates are deserters from
a corto Maltese cartel in part because
they refuse to kill on the cartels
orders instead of allowing themselves to
be sent back to corto Maltese where
they'll be killed the three plan and
escape during the tenth episode we find
Lewis the youngest of the three
cellmates carving an image on the wall
above his bunk
he eventually tells
this is Alice ooh a guardian spirit of
his home village that protects his
people in spite of dicks warnings Louise
is convinced Alice ool will help him
escape a bird that comes in the night
and saves people yes he's gonna save us
tonight and we'll be free that
conversation is part of the reason dick
decides to help the inmates near the end
of the episode literally coming out of
the night to save them and sure the
carving on the wall doesn't look much
like the costume dick eventually wears
as Nightwing either here or in the
comics but while Titans goes out of its
way to make it clear that this dude is
all about some wings viewers may have
missed the subtle meaning of that
monochromatic wall carving the word
comes from a la 'soul which is Spanish
for blue wing check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite shows
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]